o
[Música]
Olá seja muito bem-vindo muito bem-vinda
essa experiência eu sou a Leila prima eu
estou aqui porque sou mulher a
sonoridade é o que me love
e eu estou aqui porque sou mãe sua mãe
do Gabriel estou aqui porque eu sou avó
eu sou avó daí assim estou aqui que eu
sou professora eu sei que parece que eu
tenho 16 anos de idade é verdade mas eu
tenho quase trinta anos de Magistério
estou aqui que eu sou cientista o mestre
e doutor em educação
eu estou aqui porque eu estou escritora
eu estudo e público livro sobre a
inteligência emocional eu estou aqui
porque eu estou preocupado
e Como o jovem privados da sua
convivência social da sua escola saíram
dessa pandemia
e o que pais e professores estão fazendo
para promover a melhoria da qualidade de
vida deste Jovem Pan
e essa preocupação na verdade começou há
muito tempo muito antes de 2 e 20 muito
antes da pandemia nossos jovens não
estão bem ele já não vinham bem Brasil
segundo a Organização Mundial de Saúde
ocupava o primeiro lugar em crise de
ansiedade antes da academia como esse
jovem saíram daqui para lá
sabe o meu pai Ele viveu a Segunda
Guerra Mundial
aos cinco anos de idade deflagrou guerra
e ele então passou a viver Polônia
Ucrânia e Alemanha
e ele passou pelo horror de um campo de
concentração
Comodoro viu discursos de sarne assistiu
enforcamento o local
o passar dos anos agora depois que já
veio como Imigrante para o Brasil ele
está passando academismo e uma fala
recorrente dele tem me levantado muitos
questionamentos ele sempre me disse que
é muito mais fácil ninguém na guerra não
tirar foto de mim
porque na guerra havia bancas igrejas
locais para se esconder e se proteger na
padaria não
ela atingiu a todos está em todos os
lugares rico pobre indígenas Branco
moradores de condomínios fechados
moradores de rua Brasil e todos os
outros países do mundo
é uma mudança tão radical na nossa
sociedade da nossa forma de viver traz à
tona coisas que estavam escondidas
debaixo do tapete e flagra situação um
é o que estamos falando
estava falando das nossas filhas estamos
falando de uma liberação e será
impactado que precisa rádio adultos
referências somos nós
Oi Google
e Imagine que em 2020 vamos imaginar uma
família hipotética
mamãe e papai é um filho em 2020 esse
filho tinha 10 anos passaram-se 20 anos
nesse filho já com 30 cresceu já saiu de
casa Moro sozinho
Oi e a mãe e o pai então no dia do
aniversário desse filho com esse com 30
anos de dar
Vamos na casa do filho no dia do
aniversário dele
e
chega online A mãe disse assim filho
sabe livrinho caminho daquele ano que
teve aquela pampinha
Você se lembra daquele Ana que o teu
filho vai te falar Esse filho importante
que eu fosse teu filho que fofinho ele
falasse essa filha hipotética que você
sua filha será que esse filho vai falar
meu Deus mãe nem lembra daquele ano eu
faço o terapia até hoje você não me
ajudou gritava comigo o tempo todo não
deixar eu brincar eu engordei porque eu
fiquei dentro do quarto a maioria do
tempo eu desenvolvi toque por limpeza
porque você saia para trabalhar o papai
sair para trabalhar e eu virei empregada
da casa
e eu engordei demais não gosto de
exercício físico até hoje porque passava
horas e horas na frente da televisão
se você chorava muito ele tava muito não
soube lidar com problema e até hoje ou
não estabelecer na vida porque eu não
consigo dar problema
oi ou então o seu filho vai te dizer
lembro mãe
é uma aquele ano foi especial para mim
infância eu não fui para escola e mesmo
não sabendo a matéria você me apoiou mãe
olha na minha janela eu tenho ainda eu
tinha que você me ensinou a plantar em
potes de margarina naquele ano
a colcha mãe mesmo vendo que você estava
sobrecarregada com trabalho medo da
bandeirinha educando a gente eu vi que
você foi forte o que você tentava manter
a calma e isso me ensinou me ensinou
ruim hoje eu sei lidar melhor com os
meus problemas e com as minhas
ilustrações mãe Você se lembra que nós
fizemos pão e ficou blusa que a gente
viu aquele me ensinou sobre a frustração
em que a gente não precisa sofrer mas é
que o processo é mais gostoso muitas
vezes do que o resultado
é aquele ano marcou minha infância e
hoje eu sou uma pessoa melhor
é aquilo que o seu filho se lembrar
aquilo que o marcar faz parte das
memórias afetivas e e as memórias
afetivas que nós deixamos para uma
criança diz muito sobre o sucesso sobre
o comportamento dela sobre os tipos de
aprendizagem os estilos de aprendizagem
a forma como ele vai lidar com as
frustrações EA vida adulta e vamos ver
vem a razão nada fácil por isso ao
preparo 1
e nós estamos falando de crenças nós
estamos falando de Formação cerebral nós
estamos falando de problemas de
aprendizagem nós estamos falando de mais
7 de crescimento também então vamos por
par
e cuide das crenças se coloca na mente
dos seus filhos o repetir cuide das
crenças que você coloca na cabeça de
seus filhos frases como eu te amo e vou
te apoiar vamos conversar sobre o seu
sentimento
e olha se você se esforçar mais um pouco
eu tenho certeza que você vai conseguir
nós juntos podemos muito filho se você
falhar tudo bem Eu gosto de uma frase
que eu escrevi na parede do meu da minha
biblioteca quer falei tá falhado e não
se fala mais nisso quando a gente erra a
gente aprende nós crescendo filho nós
estamos juntos para o que der e vier por
isso nós precisamos conversar frases
como essa vão moldando as crenças e Não
formou um caráter melhor existe uma
coisa que não falam quase para os pais
nos vivo pelo júri tem um poder muito
grande multinacional mas não é qualquer
tipo de elogio então eu vou te ensinar a
elogiar me digam nomes assim
é o nome é um som gostoso sério veja que
você escuta o seu nome no meio de uma
multidão
Olha Nos Olhos elogio comportamento
limpar seu filho Gabriel
se você fez muito bem esses ele você
vejo que você se esforçou para arrumar o
seu quarto eu estou muito orgulhosa de
você
elogio comportamento e não inteligente
Jamais diga você é muito inteligente e
se lembre comparação não é motivação não
compare o seu filho com outro filho não
compare o seu filho com primo com um
amigo nem com todo para dizer a você o
melhor da turma nós passamos os 22
primeiros anos da nossa vida lutando
para ser o melhor sozinho mas o resto da
nossa vida nós trabalhamos um conjunto o
Pergunte para ele como você lidou quando
alguém não te escolheu para o time de
futebol como você trabalhou essa emoção
de ser muitas vezes deixada de lá o
mesmo
tipo de adulto você está formando quando
você tiver aqui da bronca no seu filho e
acredite haverá esse momento
é simpático última forma quando você x
eu Y quando você Age dessa forma eu fico
preocupada com você e se você não me
falar eu posso criar coisas em minha
mente errada
eu falei com calma e tranquilidade
sim mas mais do que isso saiba a hora de
parar
até para dar uma bronca é necessário
ouvir e falar o silêncio papai e mamãe
também se
e se você tem um filho pequeno
a turma com seu filho abraço seu filho
coloca o seu filho para dormir coração
com coração para que me sinta sua
respiração e você sinta respiração dele
chego aí
E acredite esse tempo passa muito rápido
brinque role no chão conversa e como se
não houvesse amanhã
é porque nós dormimos com eles bebê
o e acordamos com eles a dor
o tempo passa muito rápido e se você não
aproveitar o tempo de agora
terá no futuro a sensação de que você
deixou saudade de uma lacuna essa lacuna
permanecer ela
não é necessário que a gente saiba
aproveitar cada momento não desperdício
tempo com seu filho
ficando fazendo coisas frutas como no
celular vendo vídeos que não vão agregar
em nada o curtindo fotos de pessoas que
raramente você encontrará pessoalmente
enquanto você deixa de lado aqueles que
te amam de verdade é que preciso de você
de verdade
e por fim
e eu que sou mãe mãe do Gabriel eu que
sua avó avó daí assim
eu quero te relembrar de coisas muito
simples que foram esquecidas nos anos da
família
e viva a sua casa e cria memórias até
nos seus filhos agriloja comportamento
reforço positivo que é psicologia do
trabalho
e faça coisas marcantes acampe no
quintal faça uma fogueira dentro da
panela olha lua
bloco de pedrinha
o cante Dance Moms Car cabeças encontra
sua forma mais crie memórias afetivas
para o futuro porque se eu te perguntar
qual é o momento mais marcante que você
viveu com seu pai com a sua mãe
o positivo você teve Provavelmente você
se lembra de uma coisa não simples
estava trovejando e meu pai me abraçou a
minha mãe me contava Histórias Um cafuné
um piquenique embaixo da árvore do
quintal
sim mas são coisas que marcam sentimento
a Nossa Senhora Nossa deixar
Oi e eu agora eu me dispo de todos os
meus diplomas
eu estou aqui falando como mãe como
pessoa pois eu vivo a sina de ser
cientista num país que não valoriza
assim
eu estou te falando de uma teoria de uma
teoria também mas eu estou falando de
uma praia
eu fiz tudo mesmo e deu certo
e eu estou falando de uma vivência se eu
faço ainda tudo isso engrossar
mas se você tá fazendo tudo errado e
assistindo esse vídeo falando meu Deus
está tudo errado aqui uma notícia para
te dar é sempre Hora de Recomeçar
eu já recomecei muito bem eu posso
recomeçar quantas vezes forem preciso
e você pode
o touchdown e
muito obrigado